hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 there's only one more there's
only one more Challenge left in this
game and I'm probably starting out too
intense cuz I'm gonna be here for a
while but if that is 22 please but that
is 4/20 mode on five nights at Freddy's
4 or as it's commonly known for naff for
4/20 mode
probably not known like that sorry
Freddy I just can't stop staring at you
and thinking about boobs
I can't stop staring at anything and
thinking about boobs so either way I
have no idea how long this is gonna take
so I'm just gonna go for it
and I really don't know because I might
be out of practice considering I've been
away from the game for about a week I
was talking to Wade about it and he was
just getting tired when I first got to
Cincinnati and now I have no idea Harmon
do they say it's not very different so
here we go
well I've totally forgotten how to play
I'm a freak frakking idiot
okay all right I'm a freak frakking
idiot just like I predicted when I what
I didn't do what I didn't do like a
dum-dum is I didn't start listening
right away I was flashing too early I
always get that problem and you thinking
about boobies you just want to keep
flashing non-stop oops
all right now I got this I got my motor
I got my Mozart hair on not Mozart I
don't know who motes there it is
oh [ __ ] foxy here oh come on foxy you
bark at me bark for me boy whoa no
barking no barking boo
I see how this be I see how you do
wonder if the clanking means the chicas
not gonna be there all things considered
okay all right cool we're good we're
good
how's good bark good job there you
thinking about boobs in there you
thinking about boobs too me too
okay back back I think someone's on the
right I think someone's on the right Lou
oh Jesus okay almost ending shift almost
time to shoot come on I gotta remember
how to do when I shift here we go here
we go here we go here we go
come on shift alright there we go just
shifted okay oh [ __ ] that was the other
side oh [ __ ] come on fine fine
okay broke oh [ __ ] okay behind behind
behind come on come on come on
Oh shitty tits oh no oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] downs now what I want to know
when I want to go go go come on oh oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh okay we're okay you're
right there buddy boom come on come on
oh [ __ ] did he go back to the other one
did he did he did he did oh boy come on
come on
damnit what a bunch of [ __ ]
god damnit of right there on the cusp
what I [ __ ] went back to the same
side he does that sometimes and I just I
[ __ ] waited too long
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I heard breathing did he just not leave
yet I heard breathing I heard footsteps
aah
a bunch of booby boobs press the wrong
button I press the wrong button if
that's a shift about shift gears about
shift gears here bouncer you have to bad
shift so ready for this mentally in my
mind I shifted gears too soon ah
[Music]
that was the subtle one really subtle
really [ __ ] so god it's [ __ ]
faking me out dude
what what I closed it right on him I was
right there when he was there [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on Bubba Bubba Bubba pop Bob's
there's gonna be the one there's gonna
be the one because I'm not gonna be
stupid which I've been in the past
okay flu fing hair did not work I guess
when I was breathing how already how
already you just got there jeezum 's oh
my god this is going so good for me it's
starting off with a bang Hawk Fox he's
never getting back to his happy place
[ __ ] man Fox he's just to eat here
quickly quickly let me get back to him
quickly thank you Jesus get to your
happy place get to your happy place get
to your happy place
okay [ __ ] it happy place oh [ __ ] he's
not even close to with that to place oh
what am I doing wrong
dammit already with this [ __ ]
I have not been getting a break I have
not been getting a flip-flapping break
[ __ ] no one wants to give me a goddamn
break I had it up to here with all of
your ball no no I need foxy foxy foxy it
let the dogs out I have been so
victimized here I just came here to have
a good time I feel so attacked right now
[ __ ] you Foxy's this go back all the way
the [ __ ] happened different something
different oh [ __ ] you
[Applause]
we literally just started I didn't even
they haven't been here yet
what are you doing foxy Oh
oh my god I'm thank good gravy boats of
Valhalla
[Music]
[ __ ] that was that was [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where did I go to the door oh here we go
here we go there we go here we go here
we go
[ __ ] was that that was not real [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] both [ __ ] where are you what do you
keep going back to them
that real that's real that's [ __ ]
real
that's [ __ ] real [ __ ] real [ __ ]
real [ __ ] real real real real real
real real world [ __ ] I'm savoring this
one slutting this one sink in letting it
all be mine oh that was that was way
harder than people made it out to be
there was way way way harder than people
made it out to be I was I have never
been more hyper focused in my entire
life I have never been more laser
focused in on exactly what I needed to
do for so damn long and then I got
douched all over by nightmare being a
big butthole oh my why did you do a
thing about boobs oh my god like a
stress headache or something just
because I was like I was so into that
one immediately admittedly that only
took me only took me two hours compared
to all the other ones I think the first
one took me seven find x-rays who took
me like 9 the third one took me 3 or
something hours I can't remember and
this one took me 2 so technically I
guess yeah it was easier than the other
420 modes water bucket it's stupid
because I should be better at it by now
but then again this was a whole
different game mechanics whatever I
don't know I did it that is officially
the end of five nights at Freddy's 4
until new DLC comes out now before I go
there was one revelation that I totally
overlooked and totally missed which was
that when I got to the episode
that I titled the bite of 87 because I
thought of course that that was that's
what there has to be there there can be
no other thing that that is but there
was some really really really
interesting stuff found in an easter egg
in one of those modes where if you go up
to the TV and you cycle through it
enough by pressing enter or something it
shows the show like Freddie and friends
and it's labeled 1983 or 4:3 I'm pretty
sure it's three but 1983 which means
that this timeline is wrong for that to
be the bite of 87 which means that there
was another bite which I don't know some
people were saying that it was mentioned
before but I don't remember that at all
I wanted to say this all the beginning
an episode but I want to save it to the
end goes on dacoity it can't take that
long to be ditched everybody said it was
gonna be easy which is even stupider
because I got like I got to the
nightmare I got to 5:00 a.m. on my
second try officially reclaimed my crown
tang forever salad B until the DLC comes
out so I don't know what the mystery of
all this is I have no idea what the
Laura's I've never been one that was the
best to theorize about the story behind
it but I'm sure there will be some
questions answered come Halloween when
the DLC is scheduled release is that's
when it's scheduled to release which was
when the main game was scheduled to
release so I imagine we'll come out like
two weeks from now or whatever thank you
Scott so anyway thank you all so much
for watching I really hope you enjoyed
this one this was a bit of an endeavor
this was like more stressful than the
other ones because the other ones I
liked zoned out after a while and I was
like whatever if they jump scared me it
didn't even bother me but this one for
some reason every single time I died it
was still like me
leave whatever I don't know so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
all sir for supporting me through all
the five nights at freddys have now
completed every single one the maximum
capacity
I've done it all I did it good I done a
good and hopefully you enjoyed it too so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
I have another closing thoughts boobs I
thought some boobs
[Music]